[Music]
[Music]
in the beginning high above
comprehension is the word eternally
Oh which treasure with a beginning
eternally bore in the beginning Oh
paternal bosom out of which in bliss the
word flowed forth eternally
yet the womb still held fast to the word
truly of the two one flowing forth amber
of love binding both known to both so
flows the sweetest spirit in complete
symmetry inseparable the three are one
do you know what know it alone knows
itself completely the enmeshment of the
three harbours deep terror no reason has
ever comprehended this circle here is a
depth with our bottom check and mates -
time - shapes to space the circle of
mysteries is a source of everything it's
point of origin rests completely
immutable in itself
leave your doings and climb in sights
the mountain of this point the way leads
you until wondrous desert which extends
wide and immeasurably farm the desert
knows neither time nor space its nature
is unique
never has a foot crossed the domain of
the desert created reason has never
attained it it is and yet no one knows
what it is here aver far near deep high
so that it is neither the one nor the
other light clear completely dark
nameless unknown without beginning and
also without end it rests in itself
unveiled without disguise who knows what
its dwelling is let him come forth and
tell us at what shape it is become as a
child become deaf become blind your own
substance must become nothingness drive
all substance all nothingness far from
you leave space leave time as you also
all physical representation go without a
way the narrow footpath then you will
succeed in finding the desert o my soul
go out let God in sync my entire being
into God's nothingness sink into the
bottomless flood if I flee from you you
come to me if I lose myself I find you
our goodness
extending over all being
[Music]
you